and will you put to bed rumors that you
plan to cut child tax credit and
restrict our benefits to children well
thank you Jennie for that question no I
don't want to do that this report that
was out today is something I rejected at
the time as Prime Minister and I reject
it again today but I do think it's
important we go on reforming welfare
it's worth remembering when I became
prime minister we had a situation where
some families were getting 70 80 even
90,000 pounds of housing benefit for one
house and think how many people watching
this program were going out working hard
paying taxes to keep that family in that
house house they could never afford to
live in so we've got to go on reforming
welfare let's make sure that work always
pays and let's go on doing what we've
done for the last five years which is
get two million more people back into
work that's the most important thing we
can do helping people off welfare into
work that's the sort of country able to
build the next fight